in the american pool players association
is the world's largest pool league and
the eight ball nine ball championships
are going down right now at the west
gate rocky is there live to rack up uh
rack up the rules but rocky before you
take things over we we got a hold of
your back to school photo from when you
oh my gosh who is this adorable little
girl
oh
oh
that's so cute it must be you i have to
admit we had i grew up with a pool
very cute very cute back to school
picture very adorable
thank you
thank you i have to admit i grew up with
a pool table in my house so
i love me some pool and this is if you
can see behind me a huge step up from
your hometown pool hall right jason
absolutely absolutely we are here at the
apa whirlpool championships which is the
world's largest pool tournament that's
not a fancy tagline that's a guinness
record type thing so we've got over 300
tables here we've got nearly 14 000
pool players competing this week for
over 1.2 million in prize
and not just pool players but also
spectators so if you guys just like the
game of pool and want to come down and
watch you can there's shops vendors as
well and let's take a walk over here
jason um now tell us hey popeye we'll
get you we'll get you come smile to the
camera soon okay so jason you guys have
i know it's america pool players
association but
you guys got players from all over the
world here we do we've got players from
49 states here in the u.s we've got
teams from canada and we have teams all
the way from over in japan that are here
for the first time since the pandemic
began so nice to have the whole family
back together absolutely and what i also
love is that it's not just professional
pool players or you know people who take
this game real serious anybody can play
including me absolutely right rocky you
would be perfect because everyone here
at our championships are amateur players
people from all walks of life they play
in pool leagues just like they might
softball league or bowling league but at
the end of the session you've got this
huge event in vegas to come check out so
it's really unique in that way okay
perfect
with that said i'm gonna give this to
you tell us what we're doing
all right with this one you get to break
into that rack and if you make nine
balls on the break you win a million
dollars in one break
and we give every player here the
opportunity to do this so i tried the
player that makes it gets a chance at a
million bucks out i'm going to try that
again later i'll send it back to you
guys yeah thank you thank you rocky i
appreciate it rocky you get one single
ball in but we'll check back in with you
later on in the